dawn harper nelson was able to find
support through the non-profit
and mother it's a great name it offers
grants to female athletes
that help with training travel and
family support and mother was co-founded
by former olympic runner and seven time
u.s
champion alicia montano she made history
back in 2014 when she competed
while eight months pregnant in the u.s
track and field championships and alicia
montano joins us now only on cbs this
morning
alicia good morning to you thank you for
being here i think a lot of people
would be surprised and saddened to hear
that there is no support no backing
right now
for women who are on the track and also
mothers
and that's where your non-profit comes
in so talk about the situation as it
stands
and how you're trying to change it if
you could
right now thank you so much for having
me um right now
in sports i mean we're hearing this
across the board in all industries
but women are not supported from the top
down
and we know that in order to get gender
parity we need to start with the mothers
right now in industries across the board
we are faced with the motherhood penalty
and in order for us to make these
changes we know that we need to
help set an example of what it looks
like to accrue resources to listen to
learn
and to support the moms this way we
don't have
athletes like dawn that are thinking
there's no way that i can
i can do my career and also do
motherhood because i have not seen that
example
yeah the motherhood penalty is an
amazing phrase and i think
you know we all have a stake in
eliminating that penalty and
as you've tried to set up this
non-profit to eliminate the penalty
yourself what kind of challenges have
you faced
well you know first of all i want people
to remember
this started with a movement called
dream eternity and we made this movement
to our nonprofit organization and mother
and this is where the impact is
the challenges that we faced is having
women
understand that their stories do matter
that they are
validated in their decisions of their
career and their motherhood that they
don't have to choose either or
and what we've seen is people women are
still
very much afraid of sharing their
stories because they do not want to be
blacklisted from
their industry and sharing you know that
this is not something that's allowing
them to
do their very best in their career and
also do their very best in motherhood
but with sharing um our stories um
having the platform that we have with
and mother sharing the visibility of
motherhood
we hope that more women will hone in on
their voice and
know that this is what they deserve that
motherhood penalty like tony said
registered with me too elise i love that
the motherhood penalty nobody wants that
but i was struck by don's comments where
she said the sponsor said look
you've got to prove yourself first
before we work with you does that make
sense to you
do they have a point no
they don't it absolutely doesn't here's
the thing you know
over and over again one women are always
told to prove themselves i mean we just
saw
sedona you know they're there at the at
march madness
at the pinnacle of their event and
they're still
being thrown pennies and where what more
do i have to do to prove myself i'm here
we made it here um mothers you know this
is
almost saying to us that you know you're
not experts in any field
um you know you have to continue to
thrill yourself especially talking about
dawn dawn is the gold and silver
medalist she showed up to her first
olympic games
without her own personal pair of shoes
what more does she have to do to prove
herself
this is the thing also when it comes to
motherhood women are constantly being
told
and fed that we have to earn an
opportunity
to pursue motherhood if that is
something that we also choose we want to
eliminate
break down that barrier and say that
this is a path that you also can have so
alicia
it's anthony specifically what does your
organization do
to help mothers in this situation
well we are doing something very very
exciting um
right now we are supporting three core
athletes it's gonna go across the board
we have grants for smaller
uh smaller grants for um travel needs
resources
but our three core athletes are gonna be
three athletes sarah vaughan
don harper and alicia williams who are
pursuing a bit of the olympic games
and this is going to be what we want
companies to do
listen to learn to hear uh women
athletes
mother athletes in specific and say you
know i need
this resource to help me be at my best i
need this resource to help me be at my
best
and this is going to basically open the
door for women to know i'm
able to ask and for companies to know
that they need to listen and ultimately
help provide
so that you know we don't we don't have
the mothers missing i'll have to leave
it there alicia montano good to see you
can't wait to see in person you're
watching cbs this morning bye